can we stop what the female the female
here the female badasses yes can we stop
with that I do we all when is this
unwritten agreement or you'll have to
act like oh yeah yeah I'm impressed
oh yeah alias oh yeah I by the Ronda
Rousey would beat 230-pound oh yeah yeah
like like if we say something it's more
sexist or if we act as though we don't
want to see these films it was atomic
blonde now as the latest one was
Charlize Theron you can see she beats
every single man in an unrealistic
fashion and everyone tries to act like
oh yeah see women can be badass too
I just look at this that's just know
we're in the natural realm does this
even occur a Franken doesn't send her
back with female that a superhero's I
get at Wonder Woman okay it's
supernatural you can do you can do
anything you want with it but just not
like secret agents the whole kind of
female James Bond the female John wick
thing it is unbelievable and that's why
you have to suspend the laws of all
physics to make it seem like they could
win a fight I feel there was a meeting
that I wasn't there for where we're all
supposed to act as though in the right
circumstance women can be as tough as
men you should do the right Japanese guy
hidden in the mountains of some that guy
will teach you the tricks to dress
kick-ass everywhere you know it's okay
let me show you a couple let me show you
two clips here that I watched and here's
the truth is I know that films are
supposed to suspend reality but not when
the filmmakers go out and say this shows
that women can be badass this shows that
women can be just as tough as guys
that's the cell that's the feminist cell
I want to show you two clips where I I
couldn't stop myself from laughing so
hard I just removed me from it that's
why I can't watch this film let's see
these two instances and I'll give you a
play by okay
front kick that's the second time she
sends a guy flying with a front kick
that doesn't happen okay and here and
this is my favorite look
she she she takes out trained killers by
hitting them with an empty high heel
when I first watched I said oh it must
be a heel with like a blade like Austin
Powers no just whacking him with a shoe
like an old lady who it was being mugged
in Central Park okay the first one where
she's hitting with a heel just just to
prove to you how unrealistic this is and
I don't believe the symbolism of the
female empowerment the high-heeled of
feminine combined with the badassery is
not lost on me I allowed not get Jer to
hit me as hard as human
possible with his high-heeled watch okay
exact same scenario but we remove the
headrest here so that you could so he
might even be able to generate more
force Jared holding the stiletto the
exact same way clearly stronger than a
woman life-and-death struggle would this
stop me go go I love the noise he made
what are you what are you related to
downer so those who can see I'm not
saying that it's Pleasant but you would
still kill him
yeah it's unpleasant don't get me wrong
it's unpleasant but it's like your
little sister grabbing your hair think
you know and then you get her to marry
and as long as two beats her because
justice is a dish best served cold
then there's the front kick where she
front kicks and it sends a guy flying
again I notice twice we see Charlize
Theron defying the laws of physics
because her she's a strong woman two
times she front kicks a guy he goes
flying now I want to clarify it's
possible to send someone flying with a
push kicker stomp kick but to do that
you need to be going forward to gain
leverage so we are going to allow
Jarrett again stronger than a woman
surprising I know he beat Courtney in
the armwrestling match we're going to
allow him the opportunity to front kick
me to the chest as hard as humanly
possible as many times as possible and I
will stand I won't take a staggered
stance to see if he can kick me back
okay so Jared not gonna do it face me
okay lift one leg up for a second now
Edward the sound guy come back here go
back to back to make sure he's straight
okay now you can put your leg down okay
this should be about my distance okay
Edward your services are no longer
required now Jared I want you to you
could you can wind up you kick me in my
arms as hard as possible not
don't think that I he kicked me in the
balls that's how Houdini died and one
more just because bonus round the
ultimate female empowerment shot can I
as many female heroes have done in the
past hold a man against a wall against
his will with merely my stiletto this
video subscribe by clicking the letters
that spell out subscribe also YouTube
somewhere in this box has a recommended
video for you now I don't know what they
recommend but my guest says if you're
here it's going to be something twisted
and something you don't want your
parents to see if you want to see the
entire show from which this clip is
taken click one of the boxes playing
next to me that is the full episode or
join the Mudd Club for the daily show
the reason the daily show isn't on
YouTube is because well YouTube isn't
like some of the things we say